une fois par an lors de la pleine lune
un youtube heures se transforme en
immense try harder et termine un jeu
extrêmement difficile lever les yeux la
lune est pleine vous savez donc ce que
ça veut dire
ok gamin mon nom est
robot losc à son pseudo marqué sur sa
veste ok les amis aujourd'hui j'ai envie
try hard j'ai envie de mettre à
l'épreuve dont ce qu'il a fait comme ça
le bonhomme qu'est ce que ces stages de
plateforme composée de 20 niveaux quand
tu perds un niveau tu retournes au
niveau d'avant simple efficace le trend
est présent ok c'est parti donc là c'est
le level 1 logiquement c'est un peu le
mal du tout un peu pété ok on a le droit
à un double saut mexes as toi la vidéo
elle a vraiment duré deux minutes le
skill et dont nous je le sens
aujourd'hui j'avais envie travers d'un
mec ça va se compliquer l'hyper vitrail
déjà level 3 voilà non ça va encore au
top mais je vais en fait je vais finir
cette vidéo très vite non je pense que
je m'enflamme pas ok on parle direct sur
un d'accord et qu'à mon avis faut que je
parte sur un double job pourra tirer
dessus et à [ __ ] talent mais que
level-5 je perds déjà là je me suis
enflammé de quoi vous dise en quoi
d'aller vite non je rigole après tout je
suis un trader comment je vais ranger
sillages quoi peut vraiment arriver tout
haut ou à médor je vois que mon pays
avait non en vrai je m'enflamme ça en
fait quand je parle ça me déconcentre du
coup au sac donc négocié nul ce que je
parle
oui bien sûr s'est passé alors bon gars
les petits canons lacao connaît bien ça
fait huit ans que ça existe faites une
originalité ok je vais attendre la
madone est bon et la mecque ça va se
compliquer sa mère je le sais
[Musique]
oui ok [ __ ] comment je me suis
concentré on regarde ça c'est quoi c'est
que ça se casse 3 les bâtards attend
média global il dure vingt mille hommes
avec sans déconner un accord en plus les
plateformes sur lesquelles ont rebondi
ce casse d'accord alors que les flammes
car m ok lebel dauphinoise courneuve l
oms de bell alors ça comment ça marche
maintenant et voilà on est passé
[Musique]
waouh peuvent elles disent
ok là c'est le piège d'accord [ __ ]
mais c'est hyper chose on dit que des
bouts de foot ok et là c'est la sortie
ok on est bien le belle course 2011
oui oui pied
le val de noël de plus que naples ok
mais comment ça va se compliquer par
contre j'avoue au [ __ ]
je suis allé en voiture le bon gars mais
des fois ça marche ou
quoi alors d'accord c'est gratuit d open
label sommes j'étais en train de carrie
son jeu ok de retour level 12 alors
j'aimerais bien juste comprendre
pourquoi je suis mort juste une
explication peut-être on a au moins
droit à cinq ans bah ouais j'sais pas
été youtuber cuisine mec franchement
sauté plus de temps
à d'accord j'avais dû me prendre les
flammes en fait j'ai même pas vu ok j'ai
dû prendre bien pour fdp de rageux et
vous avez bien raison mais qu'est ce
parti
c'était express quoi
mais j'ai fait un double nom a par
contre eu ma barre espace eux
[ __ ] plus l'eau pelouse de blaye aux
mondiaux c'est quoi ce système là à sa
matière nouvelle loi esquiver un accord
j'ai des sceaux est limité en fait
confiance et de substances hockey un
flop birds c'est exact dans le mécanisme
que flavie bird mon gars on a grillé
l'imposture en guise un nouvel facile de
transition ça me fait plaisir
et bible belt 16 mecs level cell j'avais
mis à moi en troisième pour atteindre
level la sueur mot bigot polka 2011
oh [ __ ] je fais moins l'espace moi je
passais le wild et c'est un [ __ ] ils
nous lâchent au le bad d'art il nous
lâche direction un truc salle quoi ça
commence à être un peu compliqué si je
perds le niveau d'après je vais chialer
de refaire ce [ __ ] de level là mais
bon ok là et a sorti quatre ans ça va
enfin savoir
c'est quoi ça d'engins et les analystes
ok mais bon on est bon on est bon on est
bon ouais bon on est bon j'ai pas vu
j'ai pas vu j'ai participé [ __ ] non je
te plaît les chiens il est chiant
ok
non non mais c'est trop dur ça ne
faisait pas le droit [ __ ] et bloqué la
veille 17 quoi je pense je vais vraiment
pété une durite comme dirait mon daron
quand je vais perdre à se lever la
contrainte des rockets là j'ai compris
comment ça marche un [ __ ] c'est super
long mais celle là je ne les ai pas vus
oh [ __ ] à daya bay de marguerite
chanteur pète et matthieu rytz ayem
adultes et la maturité la maturité cas
là
j'ai mal à la diorite mais une fois tous
les cinq ans un nuage passer devant la
pleine lune et le style du try harder
baissé à vue d'oeil va-t-il réussir
malgré le nuage
[Musique]
bow wow ça commence direct
non mais c'est impossible
[Musique]
c'est quoi c'est quoi faire quoi faubert
quoi hamas qui volent what the fuck
qu'est ce que je dois faire si je dois
faire un beau geste iv en [ __ ] ça en
[ __ ] on dirait tellement impersonnel
quoi ce mec je vous rends pas refaire sa
vie d'avant ok faut que je sorte j'ai
compris il ya une notion de 3d hockey
jacques pin
a d'accord ça va être ça plein de points
d'accord c'est plein d'épreuves [ __ ]
de bar on pense à un truc avant du coup
[ __ ] non non c'est fini vos finale
mais a comme un petit pot silva
lendemain quoi tu vois là douillard
non
non non non non [ __ ] on est tombé bien
bas peut être bien parce qu'on va tomber
encore plus bas c'est ça le risque
[Musique]
[ __ ] mais je bloque à steve howard
commence à avoir mal aux yeux à fond du
coeur ne bat pas quitter des yeux mecs
vous connaissez ma capacité à garder les
yeux ouverts pour un montant
yes allez allez
on a parlé un peu mieux yes
[Musique]
allez allez
ah mais non mais non
oh non non c'est non
non tu peux venir les musiques de merde
je fais ça je fais en soit ça m'a saoulé
j'arrive plus j'arrive tout juste enzo
ferrari bon sens à ses yeux
allez allez allez
[ __ ]
non
[Musique]
non non mais déjà c'est quoi ce [ __ ]
viol mais qui tardait jeudi dernier le
belge vient le mail google
[Musique]
après tout je suis entraîneur je suis
entraîneur
[Musique]
là là si je perds tu là soit jusqu'à
c'est un truc de ouf ça je veux un avc
[Musique]
c'est parti c'est parti ça michel
sourcils c'est chiant c'est chiant ban
doit tag opposé on va l'opposer voit
l'ambiance pose est tamisée
ok la corde à sauter on comprend bien
parce que la 3d est on a fait
[Musique]
ok j'ai passé j'ai passé c'est le
deuxième label deuxième label f des
[ __ ] nasa en plus ok
ok c'est bon c'est fait
voix de femmes
ouah de femmes voilées faire quoi ok
c'est maintenant faussetés d'office et
manon hockey
ça va être le truc final je vois rien
auquel il ya un trou d'accord à chaque
fois y aura un trou et ça va de plus en
plus ok quand je comprends pas d'accord
ok d'accord ok non mais attendez ça être
d'accord j'avais maintenant comme ça
c'est plus facile de manipuler
maintenant qu'après je compris que j'y
suis maintenant ensuite sans hockey
ensuite je vais revenir un peu vers le
milieu au maire sera gauche [ __ ] ok
c'est bon j'ai réussi c'est fini c'est
fini dans ce film sera finissent par ok
[ __ ] mais que sa part rang comprends
rien je vous prends du tout j'ai réussi
je sais pas comment j'ai réussi j'ai
raconté d'accord je passe là dedans
quand je possède je vois un petit à
[ __ ] j'ai des frissons un créneau ben
voilà dans mon cul dans mon cas le
crédit temps que j'ai aussi la série
quadrillage du caire
snr ensuite là je pense que c'est assez
[Musique]
mec j'ai jamais été dans un état comme
ça devant jeux vidéo je m'en bats les
couilles de la vidéo quand je suis
désolé c'était carrément manque de
respect je voulais juste finir si j'ai
les mains glacées mec tellement je te
regarde tellement je donne toute la
puissance à mon cerveau pour qu'ils
passent ce truc mais c'est lafarge gens
là se terminer pour de vrai il n'y a pas
de piège de tout nul c'est vraiment fini
merci d'avoir joué
franchement jacques un truc à dire in
the wind
les amis n'hésitez pas à vous ça vous a
plu j'ai vraiment cru que j'allais
annuler la vidéo tellement ça m'a rendu
fou bon bref barrage personne n'a plus
de problème ça vous a plu on sentait une
brochette franchement tranquillise hyper
u du [ __ ] quand je me fais des fossés
sur var où je vais vachement relativiser
par rapport à ce que je viens de me
prendre là c'est un challenge physique
merci père de mme avoir légué ce bandeau
artengo je vous l'offre en retour si
vous voulez essayer ce jeu tenez vous en
aurez besoin la baisse la tête et le cou
à la zone rouge et noir de merde j'ai le
monde puisse
[Musique]
ça